[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i literally
i honestly believe i'll never date
another girl again oh shut the [ __ ] all
right go ahead
that's what i'm talking about and that's
not friendship i said i'll stop but you
did it okay so do it again all right so
i i this is what i'm telling you my
heart and my truth okay all right i
honestly believe
i never wanted to
i was i was thinking we were gonna just
do it
do you think we're not gonna make fun of
this is the whole thing yeah come on but
can we do this we'll do it once without
do one i don't know
give a second of honesty and
authenticity okay yeah right without
being mocked man you got it
okay
let's not do it
don't be so emotional you can do it
don't be emotional just say it you're
actually so silly dude [ __ ] you you're
not allowed to make me laugh and then be
upset that i'm laughing yeah but you're
not allowed to [ __ ] you [ __ ] you you're
right this is great
i feel like i'm [ __ ] in the middle of
just the best little fire story yeah my
bad all right so finished are you never
going to do that
i honestly believe that i'm never going
to date another girl again yeah
i believe that too why is that a big
[ __ ] deal nobody thinks you're dating
again dude okay number two she put her
knees here i'm doing a uh tiger belly
tomorrow
so this is because this episode comes
out tuesday so it'll already be done
right now so if you watch old tiger
belly if you watched if you're a tiger
belly fan bobby lee and kalil's podcast
last week on tiger belly they announced
that they have broken up they are broken
up to continue to do the podcast so i am
the first guest
i am the first guest
on their new on on the podcast okay and
if you remember
last year when i went on tiger belly
after we split the history hyenas
bobby and kalila
wore shirts or bobby lee wore a shirt
that said team giannis to [ __ ] with me
well tomorrow and we've got it made
vanity is doing it ah and it was just
homeless pimp's idea i got to give them
all the credit
i'm going on to tiger belly with a
button-down shirt and i'm going to open
it at some point in the podcast and it
will say team kalila
that's what i'm gonna do
that's what happens payback is a [ __ ]
baby you know what's interesting about
me being here today i was thinking about
this on the way up is the last time
because you guys just publicly announced
your breakup yeah the last time i was
here was when history hyenas had just
broken up
oh yeah wow
right yeah it's a breakup thing
and it's interesting
because i know it's interesting yeah
because i just was like oh wow like how
like poetic
now
because remember when i came in remember
when i came in remember yeah what what
what did you put on
team y'all
[Laughter]
yo it's the same shirt
[Music]
the whites have beat the asians once
again
just like world war ii
this is my favorite day
of any podcast i've ever done
that is so funny thank you for that
because i did i not wear the teemiana
shirt i didn't huh no you didn't you did
not i didn't
only bobby thank you for that he's going
to need a second to recover
any thoughts on why uh team kalila
um
really the only thought of truthfully is
doing because i know you guys broke up
that sad i suck the only reason i did is
because he put on the team yeah it
started be funny to put on team kalila
then team because you know i just
thought of you well you would be team
kalylah no no no no yeah in real life
you're my team right oh 100 yeah
yeah no hundred percent you guys hey
together come on that's like like so
that's a brotherhood no that's what it
is yeah but this see like something like
this doing this just [ __ ] on having
fun i love how comics heal where like
some other podcast might be like that's
offensive i'm going to sue you
talking about it i have no idea what
you're talking about but i like it we're
doing comedy here we do comedy this is
the show i know we're doing the show
coming in hot today i think we don't
edit [ __ ] today wow when you guys found
out that we broke up how did you feel oh
it makes me sad
i hate when like comedy couples break up
i
i hate like when anything happens in the
comedy community that's a bummer i take
it very personally yeah and i love you
guys together
and i'm glad that you guys are still
keeping the podcast going
i can't imagine i can't i mean i imagine
that's really hard you're trying to kiss
me yeah yeah
do you so how do you how are you working
together and are you living together
are you still living together yeah not
only just living together but nothing
has changed and every night we still
watch the same shows together we still
sleep on the same bed i mean he's almost
free yeah do you know what i mean but
you guys still live in the same place
why can't you guys be best friends
imagine you guys would be best friends
and you have your own places and she can
do her thing and you can do your thing
no when you found out that we had broken
up how would you feel
um
relief no um
our brain is wired to kind of our brain
is savage you know it's like we're kind
of wired to be madly obsessed and
attracted to each other for like two
years the amount of time it would take
to make a baby and then make sure the
guy sticks around to care for it and
then we're wired to kind of move it's
the fact that y'all have like overcome
just despite of our despite our money is
that a true thing you just said yeah we
don't make as much oxytocin and a
dopamine for someone after like two
years oh [ __ ] it makes sense
but you guys i'm saying you have beat
the eye you are so your love for each
other and your care for each other like
you've built this despite biology like
you've over you know what i'm saying is
that why every relationship i've ever
had only lasted two years or even less
yeah you stopped producing dopamine
oxytocin for the person but then you go
look yes i want to [ __ ] everything that
moves that's what i'm wired to do but
i'm choosing
this and helena bonham carter
said it when her and tim burton broke up
she's just because it ended doesn't mean
it wasn't a success
yes and half of her family died in a
plane crash oh my god think about that
yeah that's pretty good thanks so she
was definitely on purpose when she said
that was that
did you know that yeah i know
what does one have anything with the
other man we reveal too much about
ourselves and everyone knows you know
what i mean about our
intricacies and the little
little things and why did you reveal so
much you think i don't know why i know
because i've never been in a situation
like honestly when we started doing the
podcast together
we i didn't we had no one listening
no one liked it
right
what ten view you know views or whatever
so i'm just
like we'll just say whatever yeah you
know i mean so we i said i made up
stories i
in podcasts i just would do and we would
come i would just talk about our lives
in the most intimate way and then over
the time
people just started listening you know i
mean and then we became we had fans and
stuff and then all of a sudden it was
like the genie was out of the bomb we
just it was just kind of too late to
become a different kind of podcast so i
just
constantly just did it shared yeah
and it was just hard i mean i know how
you guys do it but you guys probably
don't reveal
intimate things about you guys
and
and personal things
it's probably it's probably
it's more calculated yeah so yeah not as
much for sure not as much yeah i mean do
you guys still cuddle and all that stuff
[Laughter]
when's the last time you had a cuddle
session
yeah
so you ever see this uh no no no
i want to know for myself
what's going on here
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i had been talking to a therapist and
the doctor about it wait hold on hold on
to that bobby what's happening nothing
i'm just looking at you
you're at a 45 degree bobby's got a dust
there that's a [ __ ] mean death stare
please please describe i will keep it
short he asked the question
and apparently he wants it the way he
wants it and i'd like to i'm interested
because i didn't even hear all of it
okay i knew about that opportunity to
listen
maybe there's a reason it didn't work
out bobby because you don't listen
oh you know what dude
okay
you know what to do
this is the beginning it's the beginning
it's the beginning of something i'll
tell you that and i'm beginning of
something and i can tell you guys what's
going on here because you guys are
traveling together you're still living
you're doing a show i mean this is not
this we're we're just you're welcome but
not lovers i think that we're like deep
we're mindfully and lovingly breaking up
breaking up doesn't have to be this
thing like [ __ ] that [ __ ] or all this
stuff there's no chance of a reunion we
i don't know i don't
i mean it's not my it's not my plan
right now but no like if it's if it's
you know in the books for us down the
future then then great but if not like
one way or the other is it not difficult
to spend so much time together no you
guys don't have any resentment between
the two of you i don't know wow and you
guys are comfortable like go doing these
long drives together like as platonic
friends apparently we are we did it well
that's very interesting well is it
i don't know we spend whole days
together we spend whole days together
and is there any physical intimacy still
no that's a lie what do you mean we're
not having sex but we're still like some
you know there's like no we don't do
this holding we do can we show him the
friendship yeah i do we hold hands in
public but we do it like this
it doesn't seem like a breakup
it is you guys are holding hands in
public accidentally sometimes and you
and do you guys sleep in different rooms
now i'm assuming no same beds no same
bed okay that's a little odd it's not
not
really isn't you guys sleep in the same
bed
yeah and we watch uh movies together at
night and do you guys ever like cuddle
no
we stay side by side
uh no but we're when we watch a movie on
his ipad we're about like we're pretty
close
wow
in the same bed
what's the problem pal i don't think
that's normal after a breakup get a new
apartment
how she get a new apartment i bought the
house for her
and her yeah is that wrong why is that
wrong
yeah you don't think that she'd
appreciate that she would love her okay
let me ask you something it's not like
you guys did much decorating it you know
what i mean like it's not like she's
she's
you haven't been upstairs you don't know
what the [ __ ] my house but i saw the
lego land in the in the bottom yeah yeah
i don't need to go past that i saw it
right on the bottom you get the gist of
it i got the gist of it yeah yeah yeah
yeah i walked up the japanese game show
to get to your [ __ ] house yeah right
yeah
all you need to do is put vaseline on
that driveway and have a bunch of
[ __ ] japanese people trying to make
it through it is a japanese again it's a
japanese game
and the crowd loves it when they break
their neck just
yeah they are the best at games we do
still kiss on the lips you still call me
babe we do watch the boys together every
night okay like we still sleep on the
same bed like i would just say you know
in a world eventually when you move out
yeah right and you have your own place
still i think that that would be a thing
where i would have to go
it's like if i'm on a date with a girl i
have to go you know just fyi you know i
you know my ex-girlfriends are my best
friend and we do a podcast together and
i think they'd probably know but i know
but somebody what if they don't yeah you
know i mean and date someone who speaks
english and has a wi-fi
right but i would have to like stop
dating people that just got out of cult
underground called yeah
yeah i would i would have everyone's
gonna google you everyone's gonna know
you know right right and i just have to
say that's the situation like and then
they probably ask like well is she there
all the time here's the irony the irony
is that like i actually it is a giant
red flag for me if guys aren't friends
with their exes if guys don't speak
highly of their exes if they're like
she's a [ __ ] psycho she's a
conscience that's a big red flag you're
the common denominator now these psychos
like what's going on you know so to me
there's nothing more this is why i love
before the guy that i'm dating it i got
you know he's younger but i i really
only want to date married guys with kids
before that had a lot of respect for
their child's mother because that's just
so attractive to me you know so i was
like i'm only going to date married guys
they know how commitment works like they
know how to stay uh amicable and
respectful to someone that they spent 10
years with it's a [ __ ] huge deal and
there's gonna be times where your new
guy you're gonna go have a problem or
girl whatever i don't know i don't see
gender um
where you're gonna go like i'm having a
problem i need to call bobby yeah yeah
and the man's gonna go what the [ __ ] you
know like those are those things are
going to why i envisioned a envision a
world where like like three years on the
road she has a boyfriend named tony and
i'm calling yo tony you know i can't
hang these shelves up
so you come over yeah he's like hey dude
you know hey bro i'm you know you know
i'm with goliath right now bro right and
i go come on tony come over
he comes over
right and then we're like you know
and then go hey let's play uh oh no
you're gonna recruit me
gaming let's co-op on stardew valley you
you think so bro i like yeah yeah yeah
and then we co-op
and then like six months down the road
i'm sucking this dick
it's so funny when i see you
outside of this podcast you and i are
like brother a two long lost brothers
and sisters that haven't seen each other
i mean the way we hug you're my god and
we hug and on here you're rolling your
eyes and doing all these okay you have
like non-sugar-free red bull energy
right now like you need
exorcism with your new look yeah i feel
you're a an
like did oh my my luck my sassy i was
going to say something i thought that
that was her real look that this is
something she's she's taking it for a
spin yeah she's like what is my new look
that's what i'm saying you she's going
back to gotham goth mom that's who i am
that is so good i think post breakup i
think i need a new look and i'm shopping
for one well come on over it's a short
hour and a half in makeup can we do you
like can we throw it back to like troll
um chola guy hell yeah we can dog okay i
would love to do a cholo guy bobby i am
here for you why don't we go shopping
together i would love to go anywhere you
want you know what's my treat
whatever you want daddy what
no being real do you want to embrace you
want to call them girls
shoes do you want to go do you want to
embrace a new look i'll do anything you
want me to do baby okay
i'll wear the chains
and i'll walk around your house
and i'll park
i'll
okay who's your dream girl
who's the girl that you're like it's
unobtainable she's a famous person
everybody knows whose this is she's so
hot i'm not gonna get her but it's a
thing like a taller natalie portman
natalie portman let's get her enroll
she's a great actress she could be a
collaboration
all right we'll stretch her out someone
that looks like that but has that skills
into this acting this is this is your
crush forever yeah but she's gonna be
five inches taller i like taller girls
she's still taller than you
[Laughter]
nobody speaks english to me
what are we trying to do what are we
trying to
say
right two words cheap labor okay
i have called you on text with you
before yeah but if it's something if my
life is blowing up
when i found out headline you'll call
headlines
right right yeah i mean bobby's dying
you'll call right i know when you but in
a random day like if it's raining you
you safe
yep but i don't know the la weather
system that's true but when you when you
announced the breakup what did i say i
called you did you yes i don't think you
were on the phone
we did yes bobby oh my god
on the phone let me just look i want to
look at our text exchanges because
remember what i said to you you know a
few days ago i said how are you coping i
said i would assume that these things
personally have been going on for a long
time but now but now publicly since
you've made a statement it's going to
get difficult and i want you to let you
know i'm here you said i want to talk
about i want to talk about that you said
after you know evan williams
so you very quickly brush it off well
that's because i because
the reason why is because i called you
not because of my personal life yeah but
because i wanted you to see what you
thought of this but while he has you on
the phone he wants to know what how your
heart is when i'm calling for one thing
i need to get that overwhelmed okay yeah
right and how about this
in an effort to you when cause you had
call i we were playing phone tag but
when you called me back i went because i
knew how important it was that you i
thought maybe you're calling about this
that maybe just needs someone to talk to
i was trying
showing my daughter how to ride a bike
with just taking the training wheels off
and i let go of the of the seat handle
to pick every call and she fell
is that real sorry real true story she
was fine she fell through patrick grass
she was like why'd you let me go i was
like bobby's on the phone oh
okay well then she's fine you know what
i don't like when you just brought that
out you know what i don't like what when
comics
kids don't know who their friends are oh
yeah you were upset that christians died
but christchurch doesn't the daughter
doesn't know who i am well you're not
even going to july 4th barbecues i mean
that's true that's what i'm saying
that's why i wanted to go anyway you
know what i mean but your kid knows
because if i had a kid they would know
your name even though you have a [ __ ]
up last name it's hard to say my kid
knows who you are she thinks you're
mulan
bobby was checking a girl out when we
were in san diego who was the girl oh
i'm sorry let's go my boy
who is the girl hello
you're doing it you were doing it you
were doing it what nancy pelosi who was
it was
was it nancy pelosi
she wasn't 80 listen all right but you
like big [ __ ] [ __ ] that's not what it
is yes you do
you like fat tits bro and you like white
girls with fat asses yeah who wasn't
supposed to it was like nancy pelosi yes
it was
yes it was
it was that it was that and you want to
grab jewels [ __ ] [ __ ] you jules
[ __ ] you jules you've done good this is
where
we never really she is the love of my
life and i love her dearly and um she
changed me in so many different ways
that being said um
we broke
yeah
up
yeah yeah and this is the first time
you know i don't know if this is we'll
hold this episode until you hold it
right now we'll not swallow it yeah yeah
because i really would like to meet her
i i saw her for 10 seconds at
christina's party yeah and you as well
you came in bowed to me and bounced and
then i was like magical
i was dressed like i was in the 80s yeah
yeah i don't know what it was it was
dark is that a magical gnome and uh um
and i would love to have her on here too
yeah but uh i did not know you you guys
broke up no one knows this is the first
time i've talked about it well
we'll hold this episode yeah this
literally is the first time i've talked
about it on a podcast you're a man bro
that's right you could look at however
that's true that true that okay yeah
you're in a mall i know it's your
[ __ ] world you're bobby lee you're
right you're single ready to mingle
should i stuff that face in some fat
white girl
but it's so funny that you white dudes
why do you use like not white bro
whatever you're both a town you italian
dudes yeah they're a taller fairly good
looking right very funny at your craft
right i thought it was good you think
you're like you [ __ ] podcast you said
i look like zilberg you think it's
easier
it's easier for you to get women
than for me to get one yes that's the
system we've developed i know
the world and it's also easier for you
to get food in america so you came here
so you have to put up with that that's
the sacrifice you make when your family
brings you here it's a little harder to
get laid but there's food every day and
a refrigerator right
it's a little bit harder
there's food every day and there's a
refrigerator that's just what it is it's
funny but i want to fight you
it's funny
this is what your family worked for it
is harder for me than you guys it is no
it's not
do you get dms have you tried do you
guys get dm's have you tried
just girls that you don't know they just
go send you breast pits kicks breast
picks yeah
how big are they
er every variety you know what's crazy
about you because i know you like a fat
white kid i do
dude and you're like a little kid around
them aren't you oh i giggle kitty yes i
do you want to shake it shake them i get
digging like i'm in a [ __ ] take me to
it's like you know jumping into the with
those little red yellow balls that
little
ball pit the ball the ball pit yeah i
can't he already said that i like it
yeah hey yeah the reason you're you're
not getting dms is because everybody on
earth knows that you're in a
relationship there you go now you're
going to get girls that are going to go
hey i'd like to hang out with you what's
going on bobby you're single they're
going to be thrown at you like crazy
dude you're single now yes but people
didn't dm you because they didn't think
you were singing
oh you don't want it no you don't you do
want it i don't want no you you're i
don't feel i love kalylah and i would
never betray her why would that be
betrayal
the worst um thing about breaking up
though is being at the comedy store
because there are people
that i never talked to
that are going like i'll see them and
they'll be like bring it in oh god you
hate that and i go what they're all just
so psyched kyle is single
but it's like even
people i've barely talked to
come on buddy
right and i'm like and i have and i want
to be a dick so i'm kind of like okay
and i'll just kind of give them a a hug
and they're like man if you need ever
need anything oh they're doing the [ __ ]
i don't know you have any of you gotten
dms from people trying like i've um i
finally got my first one
oh really what did it say why are you
you don't have to be i just
i got excited it was my one and only
i've never gotten
yeah go ahead go ahead i want to another
yeah and i don't want to get into it but
it was like you know one body don't one
body part yeah yeah and you know me she
said uh i want to [ __ ] you it was it was
kaila it was me it was a [ __ ] burner
yeah my favorite first one was it did
you go to the person's profile to see if
they were mentally
they probably are mental it might or i
already make an assumption that they are
happy that they're out of their what's
wrong george
why are you rolling your eyes back
well i threw this podcast have had two
of those so uh i was a surprise that
you've only had one
do you guys call him nazi theo
i'm not interested in meeting anybody
else but if i were to be somebody else
yes he is what do i need to do because
would you and kyle ever role play as
like neighbors
oh we do
oh yeah like i'm gonna get you an airbnb
for a little bit
we both have not dated in 10 years we
probably need your help yeah
we get back together
[Music]
you